18 ans qu'il est associé au prieuré de
la charité-sur-loire luc jolivel
directeur de la cité du move a pourtant
quitté la structure au mois de mars
prochain
après trois ans en fonction il arrive au
bout de son mandat et ne se représentera
pas je pense que j'ai apporté ce que
j'avais apportées aux monuments en 18
ans énorme
voilà et je pense réellement qu'il il
faut maintenant que ce soit d'autres
compétences qu'ils soient mobilisés au
profit du prieuré et ses compétences
aussi il faut le dire je pense français
un nouvel élan pour le projet un départ
qui s'inscrit dans un contexte chaotique
la cité du mot a dû annuler en partie
les derniers évènements de sa saison
faute de budget dans un contexte
économique difficile la baisse des
subventions et des partenariats privés
se fait cruellement sentir au détriment
des ambitions de la structure le
festival du mot grand rendez vous annuel
ne serait pas menacée mais avec un
budget limité de 620 mille euros par an
la cité du mot doit se repenser pour
tirer parti au mieux du pee wee
restaurer c'est un monument qu'on a tiré
de l'ombre la belle endormie s'est
réveillée et résolument on pense que le
cycle patrimoine sa chef pour laisser
place un cycle culturel c'est à dire que
vraiment ce soit la cité du mot qui
prennent le pas sur le prieuré de la
charité il reste donc six mois pour
trouver un remplaçant au directeur
historique et définir un projet qui
puisse fédérer de nouveaux partenaires